welcome to the 2016 Los Angeles podcast
festival it's our fifth year and that's
fancy and our third year with the live
video stream so that's like eight years
if you don't understand math and time
like every year we are thankful we no
longer have to deal with that stupid
elevator at the Santa Monica venue this
podcast festival has turned into a
community of people who come each year
to see their favorite shows and to see
each other again we couldn't be happier
we get to put this on five years ago we
were just podcasters trying to figure
out this medium and now here we are
we've created a podcast festival by
podcasters for podcast fans that's the
way it should be and we are able to do
this every year because of our sponsors
area for life Casper mattress libsyn
Nixon Peabody pod xref satchel spare men
wandering please silent cell phones no
video recording with your cell phones
but you can take pictures just don't be
annoying about it I'm talking to you
Jeff now it's time for another podcast
live from the Los Angeles podcast
festival
I wore a sweatshirt it's the it's the
pajamas that Gotham needs right now you
guys Oh real quick it's Graham you guys
that does that I knew you guys like holy
[ __ ] they got Batman to be a guest oh my
god it's pretty amazing I know everyone
was like you ever knows where Batman's
around but you can't find Graham at the
same time hope Nightwing can take care
of Gotham ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the 2016 Los Angeles podcast fest
this is god bless each and every one of
you especially those that bought a full
weekend pass you cheap day pass [ __ ]
you know who you are um no this is so
great like and we appreciate you know
it's like every year the did it gets but
it gets more packed when we do the show
and hello to everybody watching a live
stream wherever you are in the world all
of you in China om hide everybody in
Japan konichiwa everybody in Australia
have a dingo farmer or whatever whatever
you're doing so say how do those people
a bit of tough dingo harvest this year
oh my god when there's a dingo drought
you know said oh my god it's it's out
its out what their whole economy is
based on sending it is a dingo based
economy folks please look this up this
is a news program yeah um so before we
get started I think we have something
very exciting adry haha you goddamn
right yeah Batman pajamas aren't free
guys yeah we are very excited to have
one of our sponsors here casper
mattresses yeah have you guys checked
them out over in the corner very cool
right yeah born of their pillows they
have and someone said oh wow it's like a
head mattress
sounds like Casper has some new
marketing slogans yes so go guys check
out the head mattress that they have
over there in the Casper corner and what
is it what is the bed a pillow for your
body yeah it's a body pillow and a head
mattress you guys um so go check that
out yeah those I you I didn't sleep with
a hotel last night I slept in my own bed
because it was [ __ ] great on the
Casper mattress and it's if you go to
Casper com / comedy film nerds and use
our coupon code which is cfar cupen our
coupon code our coupon code a cuckoo use
your coupon code on a Tuesday yeah I
know and it's a great program and have a
robe it yep enjoying I'm the scientist
and a 50s sci-fi movie well there's some
kind of a robot there are many things we
don't understand about this universe and
some of them are frightening and then
you like talk down to the female actress
actually a robot is like I get you some
coffee yeah a robot is like a human much
like you use a vacuum cleaner when you
view your women chores but casper
mattresses are comfortable ladies a
gentleman so when your man's planning
something use it out of castro masters
but use your coupon code use your coupon
code and save fifty dollars yes it'll be
CFN or comedy film rights try both you
have plenty of time we didn't have time
to research what the coupon code was we
put it on a grasper at every month and
we can't recall what it is but we've
narrowed it down to switch gears to see
a fan or a no but guys know what it is
see you don't know you [ __ ] yeah
nice job by a three-day pass and a
goddamn mattress you sons of [ __ ]
you know I'm really excited about nope
yeah me either ah certainly wasn't
research of the coupon code no we had a
lot on our place oh my god uh well you
know what I think it's time to introduce
our guest well okay I know I think it's
a great idea it's a fine idea ah ladies
gentlemen our first guest you may
recognize from the popular podcast we're
going to screw up every fourth word
welcome to the Los Angeles podcast
feisty pile uh may just join uh the the
voice really of the the Mel Torme of my
lifelines using laser on the voice of
welcome to night Vale Cecil Baldwin come
on
hello I can you just do like the intro
to night Vale just that would be great
Oh quick weird stuff for yourself weird
stuff welcome to night Vale we were on a
panel earlier and I was trying to be all
like panel business I was just like I
just want this guy to just read the
phone book yeah this Roger trying to
hear him still existed I would want him
with like heart I emojis yeah it's just
like coming out everyone like wow do I
need an anti anti anxiety pill or just I
want to hear you talk that's really
great I just feel better about
everything now yeah you should you
should your voice should be anti-anxiety
meds yeah it's like Billy some
pharmaceutical representative if you
were reading Nazi propaganda I would
still feel better about it down so
soothing yes oh my god this master race
myself oh he's making some great points
yeah maybe we should be separate yeah
horrible but it's so relaxed yes could
could you to welcome to comedy film
nerds welcome to comedy film nerds
that's going on a bumper yeah if we got
a radio we got to get you to record that
Nazi that's better than our fumbly into
shows will commit episode 33 37 check
your phone that's literally how we
figure out spoiler up numbers yes
alright spoiler up well what is it we
what I God we have the app we pull out
the cover we're the only ones really
using it so we have a CF an app for us
we made them build it for us uh I wish
we were joking yeah I'm sorry sorry
lipson anyway
yeah I think it's time to introduce our
next guest I'm very very excited about
our next guests we've been promoting him
a lot on the podcast but I gotta tell
you you know a lot of you guys spend a
lot of time on the internet and enjoy a
lot of nerding things so chances are you
don't know who this person is so we'll
have him do a little buyer I don't think
I don't think there's any crossover the
TV show he worked on but ladies and
gentlemen wil wheaton so I've been
wanting to ask this for ever since we
booked you on the show what do you think
of the horrible new Star Trek movies I
really enjoyed the first one I mean it
had problems in it but you know I think
that once we accept that our bodies can
be broken down into individual atoms and
sent thousands of miles away we can
accept some fudging of the way a black
hole works like I'm okay with that a
fair point I enjoyed the second one in
the theater but the farther away i got
from it the more and more i started to
dislike it and I sort of like saw all
the problems with it I was unbelievably
disappointed with the most recent one
and by the time they got to the shitshow
of the third act I had turned on it so
by the time they get to that thing where
they're like what is that classical
music and the audience is supposed to go
wow I was like I'll [ __ ] you you didn't
earn that we just got Wil Wheaton to say
[ __ ] you on our podcast
I i was i was super disappointed and I
wrote I wrote a thing about it on my
blog that was surprised savaged by Star
Trek fans where I was like look you know
like we can we I think that that like we
can like things for what they are and I
think that we have to give a little it
went when we're when we're making things
like that because they don't have the
luxury of telling a story over 40
episodes or or a hundred episodes like a
series does and they have to like a
series can presume a certain amount of
knowledge on behalf of the audience if
you tried to drop somebody into mr.
robot in like the fourth episode of the
second season they would be slightly
less confused than someone who has been
watching it from the beginning and and
and like so like that you you know you
you can't really do that with with a
movie so the thing is Star Trek like has
stands for certain things that sets it
apart from generic sci-fi action movie
and what I saw in Star Trek beyond was a
generic sci-fi action movie and star
trek cosplay and it was a giant
disappointment to me yeah I was a pretty
people space fight yeah yeah and you
know Anna and a huge problem i had with
it like a huge problem that i have with
that i think is directly at odds with
kind of what i think Star Trek is about
is that you have this amazing phenomenal
ass-kicking female character who can do
almost anything and the instant Captain
Kirk shows up she becomes the girl for
him to save and and I hated that I felt
like that was the sort of trope that
Star Trek should subvert not not play
into yet I think we talked about episode
because I I saw ratha con on the big
screen I think we're all in agreement on
this side yeah the latest Star Trek
movie no wait wait wait wait hold up as
long as Chris Pine just keeps taking off
his shirt I'll show up
oh oh its twenty dollars excellent yes
you're always seeing that in three
dishes for I'm actually really you sure
you don't see him take off his shirt and
I max it's he's doing the Salmon Ladder
25 yeah yeah which is not to say that
like look if you liked it awesome i'm
glad that you enjoyed that film see I
disagree I'm not glad if you enjoyed it
oh I think yeah I think it's great I'm
severely disappointed in humanity yeah I
have extreme reactions the liking Star
Trek is the fig aside all the other
crazy on the world right now ya know
that's what set me off you like Star
Trek beyond burn it all down yeah the
country's divided people are dying from
gun violence that goddamn star trek they
aren't you son of a [ __ ] it's all
related Graham you're right so we what
we like to do sear it cut together a
clip of all of the Chris like I say
something kind of [ __ ] up and then
Chris goes okay so our next movie like
someone should put all of those together
the transition guy yeah yeah what we
like to do with this show the live shows
up office we'd like to really dig into
the trailers of upcoming films and we're
going to be showing you the good the bad
and the ugly sadly i'm going to give you
a spoiler it right away couldn't find
one in german this year we try we had
our german employee aaron baumgart we
literally told him find a bad trailer in
german and he couldn't do it was weird
because last year he was like yes mine
gonna roll and he rent got it this year
he was like uh neat what was it yeah
yeah he found if you were here last year
remember he found the last witch hunter
and he put the wrong trailer on and it
was in German
I let's be honest there was only a
German witch hunter trailer yes they
didn't spend the money on an English one
hey maybe want to see it more and since
I don't can't I don't understand what's
going on what it was called died last
with ya feel a snitch on job yeah open
diesel is mumbling in German yeah how
could you tell yeah exactly oh god he's
so pretty well I think we should just
start off with the first okay wait yeah
vin diesel or Jason Statham Oh Jason
Statham ok I just want to make sure I
want to make sure that's the correct
answer but yeah I love that even though
like Vin Diesel's gang right isn't he
actually it's sure why not in a German
trailer everyone is thi la sua conta I
can't wait to see that trailer don't
Google der schiessen hunter I know you
want to but just don't all right so
we're gonna ears are uh ladies gentleman
here is our first trailer of the evening
look to either one of these monitors
they will not be playing on her faces
yes I'm gonna bring the house lights
down perfect
a little staring at agrees
you
notice that's the American trailer so
you don't [ __ ] see Godzilla till the
end
which is still more than you saw
Godzilla in the 2014 Godzilla was right
there why are you talking about Godzilla
we just watched the Japanese trailer for
Cloverfield I'm very confused is that on
these notes all right so guys what do
you think you're excited about this not
excited what do you think well I think
that if you have to say this reboot is
unquestionably Godzilla maybe that's a
problem Cecil uh yeah show up for this
one I'll show for this one just
Godzilla's hot no just tell me oh so hot
burns it up no um I mean I'm always
curious about like when they you know
what they have like foreign films that
they try to market to Americans by
having no one speak like it like we're
not gonna put together the fact that you
know like if we hear a foreign language
we're just like run screaming from the
theatre I'm always a little bit insulted
by that in America lately yeah build a
wall around the car damn Godzilla I'll
tell everybody stead of it back yeah I
gotta I gotta read subtitles I'm going
to the movie doesn't know book show
that's how time to liberal motion to me
yeah it's my partner ring books I go to
France with john kerry i will say this
this movie looks like probably the most
monochromatic film i think that's been
released in a while you know like oh yay
japanese office workers this is gonna be
a feast for the eyes
now okay here's the interesting thing
that's the American trailer for the film
and it's horrible if you actually go
online and watch the Japanese trailers
you realize that well there's no reason
to cut a horrible trailer for this film
hey why don't you subtitle the trailer
that actually shows the film I'll tell
you what that trailer is that is an
american distributor going hearing all
the voices that we just did going
alright we gotta do this what if they
had half a brain they would go market
this to [ __ ] nerds you market this to
everyone in this room that has a plastic
Godzilla yes thats are on their
bookshelves Maria to everyone in this
room and we'll sell 61 tickets 6262 oh
yeah and Batman pajamas guys gonna come
no he's not bringing any friends and he
may not yeah he may not I I probably
yeah I I I think I honestly when I first
heard about this movie before I saw that
trailer when I first heard about this
movie I was like oh this will be great
because it's the Japanese thing it's
their story they'll get it right they
won't [ __ ] it up the like the last one
that was done here in 2014 and then i
watch that trail and I'm just like oh
and i can't i know i'm just like is it
is the movie actually horrible or is it
gonna be a really cool fun godzilla
movie and this trailer did it no service
wait who is clamoring for yet another
godzilla remake who's like oh man what i
really need to see this year i can't i'm
sure glad that that money wasn't
invested in something new like bring
back Matthew Broderick please
he'll save all of Tokyo this time
someone should have cast alan ruck in
the lead and just had the those two
movies fight i would pay to see that put
them in pacific rim mechs yeah and just
project the both movies on each mac and
just be like yes we're making a
statement yes and we're going to have
the mechs fight in rain and water so you
can't see anything that's happening that
sounds riffic i mean the fact that like
like asian horror is like is one like
they kill it every time like I faith I
faith that this will be good yeah you
know like Oh be suspenseful like the
characters will actually be like fleshed
out you know it kind of the opposite of
like American hollywood-style like
action horror yeah let's hope fingers
fingers crossed their ass I have faith
in this I I want to see it because I
really feel like you know the Japanese
studios have seen all right you know the
Americans have screwed up Godzilla
enough we're gonna make a real Godzilla
movie again and then it's going to be
ruined by a horrible American trailer
that's the plan that's that's in the
marketing place oh and then ended to
follow it up with like horrible American
dubbing probably yeah we can only hope
there's sounds like we all have a lot of
hope and faith so let's all grab hands
and bow our heads I have a moment of
silence for shin Godzilla all right all
right now I want to play this next
trailer and when i play it i want you to
count how many cliches are in it do we
start backwards from 100
all right trailer number two they'll
happen here one one guy to come all down
with his bare hands to he's still in
there three turn around mr. one chance
slowly oh [ __ ] one thousand felon in
this state mr. Reacher process him and
get him to County two things are gonna
happen in the next 90 seconds for m5
first that phone over there is gonna
ring 6 second you're gonna be wearing
these cuffs on your way to prison that
is one magnificent prophecy so are we
counting his accent oh yeah that's right
she's gonna keep on ringing you just got
Reacher dipper better reach arounds
folks wonder why you left Purple Heart
Silver Star there's this big dent in the
dust people say you made it with
someone's honey Jack creature from agent
Turner major Turner has been arrested on
what charge espionage he's been sent him
a hundred yeah region know how's it
going don't want being followed you
think you're a vulnerable side maybe I
rip your arm off beat you to death with
it I'm sorry feature here to kill you
my men were shot I want to borrow this
is bigger than I imagined haha
you're a good man
track is 11 so long
but I'm not the law so you should start
running cuz I'm gonna start hunting and
when I find you I'm gonna kill you all
oh it's a haircut oh you guys go to the
same barber Wow guys so don't get that
haircut it'll cause someone to play a
sound one man one man's mission to
eliminate the world of this really
generic haircut there can be only one
has that haircut um yeah I guess I'm as
excited as everybody has to see this
never go back I was gonna go comma
please i wil wheaton your thoughts on
this fine piece of cinematic trailer
ring i'm outside the demo on that on
this movie because i just can't stand
Tom Cruise as an actor we SAT them all
on the right side of the road but look
but look but that said that trailer
tells you exactly what you're going to
see in that movie yet I mean it tells
you it's like hey if this is what you
want we are going to deliver this movie
and good for them it's not like your
guys say Jack Reacher at the end right
yeah it's I think review you know in
something like that like you're gonna
see you know handsome mix Xenu punching
people and and like great on the wrong
side of the government or whatever cool
I mean it's hashtag handsome exceed ooh
that there's there's nothing complicated
about that I bet it has some really
great set pieces I imagine he leaps from
at least one moving vehicle to another
there's gonna be a couple of was in that
film and like even if the trailer
supposed to advertise the movie great it
did that it showed me a movie that I
have no desire to see but I know that
I'm way outside the demo on that and
that movie's gonna open huge
so maybe I'm the one who's wrong no no
it is the children seezle Baldwin your
thoughts on that fine haircut movie oh
man so as soon as I saw Tom Cruise
punched through a windshield into a
dude's face I immediately started
thinking wow Jack Reacher Jack creature
Jack like it kind of sounds like Jack
creature and I was like maybe this movie
title should be yah creature ja creature
so maybe it's like yah creature would be
a better movie title and then it was
over so you're you're trying to get this
movie in German yeah but that I think
yah creature is a dirty scheisse porn
version of this film where it's just
that guy in like a latex suit getting
[ __ ] on the entire movie and like y'all
creature yah creature Chris's kids are
here yeah not for much longer yeah it's
always a point I'm amazed they're still
here they usually don't make it this
long usually I used to Tyler walk them
in four seconds left yeah yeah yeah but
yeah I might know glad I would like like
will like my brain just kind of turned
off everything else like that's nice
okay I wonder like what would what could
the notes possibly be for like a script
like that like more elbow fist fights
yeah that's what this movie needs that's
like one of those movies that is gonna
that movie kind of transcends language
and culture because it's just you know
handsome guy punches people and those do
extraordinarily well at the box on
transcend over the world or descends
either way I mean I'm just I'm just
sayin like that's why those movies get
made yes because you could put that in
literally any language like you could
you could put that like you could you
could put the Charlie Brown you to
trombone over all the all the dialogue
in that and you get exactly the same
thing and it's and you're either Yeah
right or you're like oh is this over yet
I'm not
actually make me want to watch you more
oh god i think somebody needs to go do a
supercut of like those lame guy punching
thing trailers where it's just more walk
walk walk this goes all the way to top
off our mom I want want but I was set up
want want want want and then the other
guy comes in but it's like these movies
that tell you exactly when to go to the
bathroom you know as soon as the talking
starts that's your cue to get up and go
pee and then come back for more pretty
people punching each other yes uh I
watch this movie and I go ah this is
great this will get me through a flight
I think I'm like I'm like oh there's two
hours on a flight like I can go it's
four hours from here to chicago i'll do
that and then flip around and go all
hours into their CBS sitcom I don't want
to watch and then I'll read a book fair
enough no one doesn't think I can read
okay I know what that's a very point
like come on Graham seriously you're
watching the CBS sitcom a batman
coloring book is not reading no matter
how you try to do the adult coloring i
strongly disagree sir the batman
coloring book has many words in it and
not all of them are sound effects of a
fight that i'm coloring in good point
good point and it absolutely counts
toward my book goal in my Goodreads
challenge but Graham next time stay
inside the lines alright uh don't you
shut down his creativity thank you well
you're welcome I would also like to i
would i would like challenge everybody i
wish i could go back and like count the
number of people of color in that
trailer oh wait there were none so that
answers that question it's like it's
like it's literally don't be watching a
podcast festival Oh
whoa Chris Wow Aisha canceled dancing
yeah it just got intensely real in here
before white dudes uh yeah yeah we
opened a white we were saying that I you
can for tomorrow and but she sent us a
video and it's hilarious you get to
watch it before walking the room I
suggest you don't miss it it is amazing
there's the one black person at the
festival so you got to watch that video
so I think it's time for the next
trailer but now this is an interesting
trailer this is actually a remake on a
classic holiday tale trailer number
three
don't come over here with that damn
bonuses no no no no we fight night so
i'm chillin by Tiffany what's going on
Shalom pops cool hey my dear I got to go
out of town I was wondering if you can
come by and just keep an eye on tipping
oh no I could come over to your
halloween like you know that's going
around Halloween I'll pay you I'm on my
way i'll be there now I'm glad you're
here to help me with her cuz there's a
party around corner and I want to be
sure she doesn't try to sneak out he's
so while these children today you got to
drop the hammer on me I brought the
birthday can app do it turn the
prostitution drugs yeah how you think i
met your mama you shouldn't be here mr.
Wilson died in this house on Halloween
he killed his entire family after 10
strange things are happy do you want to
play a game show us your boobs you want
to see you be home there were guys who I
did a dream home I used to
way up our winner let me look up on the
hood all right come on scared are you
nothing Tyler Perry spoo a madea
Halloween who's camping out for that
midnight screening there were moments
with beginning we all got another bonus
we all kind of went oh wait that was
kind of funny I would like to get her I
think will is broken so wil wheaton um
you going 3d on this water well I'm I'm
glad that they use super freak and study
you can't touch this
what fascinates me is how it is how you
know there was so probably a development
meeting it's like you know there is a
giant hole left by no more earnest
movies we gotta get after that jim
Varney money yeah and we need it now are
demanding it admittedly I would just
love like 10 minutes in tyler perry's
wig room because you know that it's like
the size of this hotel convention center
just like like a kid in like like Willy
Wonka's trunk effectors is like oh look
at this one oh hell no and then like
talk about 1 i'm alright come on another
one like that would literally be my
greatest Christmas wish yeah like I want
to shoot that I want to film that seed
and it's like moving and you each one
you put it on and you say all hell no in
a different kind of version like I'm
tired oh hang on hahahaha little dry and
at the end you find out that madea's
been inside you all week doesn't matter
you never needed the wig see soldier
we all have a little Medea in us I just
clamoring to get out I just want to know
if she attends Chekhov's party that they
set up in the trailer nice reference
that was uh I was solid shut down half
the room that reference was fantastic
but he's decided to a party in the first
act you know what I think they all need
to recover from that last trailer for a
few more seconds I'm excited to see it
uh I want to see it because you know
what I will I will I will quote Wil
Wheaton said about Jack Reacher I know
exactly what's gonna happen in that
movie yeah I the minute I heard about
that I was like oh there's gonna be some
I don't know a punching a ghost like you
ain't ghost in me bitching or whatever
like I know that's nobody doesn't say
that but I know there's gonna be
handbags on a zombie's head like I know
that's gonna happen but that big floppy
boobs yes Big Papi boobs doing things
yeah and and I knew that was gonna be I
knew there was gonna be I was gonna be
wigs Yeah right and I knew there was
going to be a ghost and are the same as
white people you know like I knew that
was gonna let's go stop don't just write
me what this curry you know what I me
like I that was I did have everything I
wanted isn't this like it's just like an
extended Eddie Murphy takami routine
from like the late 70s or like they from
the early 80s like Lily just like he
covered all that ground yeah I think it
aspires to be and that's like it's like
the high school talent show competition
version of that of that set but the
thing is like Jack Reacher it's going to
make a [ __ ] ton of money it has an
audience and it's it's good I mean Tyler
Perry is the most successful like
playwright his movies just [ __ ] cleans
up he knows exactly what he's doing you
know exactly what his audiences and he's
any controls every part of the
production is very successful filmmaker
producer you know and for that I'm like
I can go Madea meets Jack Reacher like I
want to see that
I want to I want to see Jeffrey to the
greatest double feature ever Yeah right
wouldn't I wouldn't it be good love to
do that mashup we're like Jack Reacher's
like the phone was gonna ring what you
call hits hindman like they team up like
Jack Reacher and Medea fight some shadow
government just about that like ESO
decker yes the like take her hostage as
like his body shield and then has to
take her with her it's a remake of The
Bodyguard with Medea and Jack Reacher
all right when are we set up the
Kickstarter period right now yeah if
that movie gets made it was my idea and
hell no can we call it the body Reacher
oh yes yes Chris Mancini ladies and
gentlemen yes you do it all right this
next trailer I'm not gonna say anything
about this next trailer let's take a
look trailer number four please
hello he asking me on a date she didn't
seem that impressed you clean up pretty
good yourself don't you look fine this
evening we're on a date very nice took
you long enough to ask
so why did you give up your life on
earth oh hell no
we boarded the abalone with the
destination 120 years hibernation means
a wake up in a new century on a new
planet but a year ago everything changed
Oh
do you know what's going on but nobody
else is awake I think something went
wrong with the hibernation box you woke
up too soon
and years too soon
r you should go back to sleep with yet
something's wrong something big
what do we do
do you trust me
it's something I have to tell me
there's breezy we woke up early
did anyone else notice laurence
fishburne in like a mass effect uniform
I just say this at first it looks
interesting to me but the first 10
seconds I thought it was like an LG
product launch wil wheaton what are your
thoughts on that trailer well you knew
it wasn't an LG product because it
lasted longer than 10 seconds because
down before it caught fire yeah ok so I
have a couple of thoughts about this
number one we love to project ourselves
into movies especially like me science
fiction movies and stuff in that
especially where they're kissing each
other I don't know if I'd rather be
Chris prouder Jennifer Lawrence in that
particular scenario so that's a thing
I'm gonna have to work to unpack for a
really long time I'm probably going to
lose a lot of sleep while I figure that
out it looks very interesting to me and
I kind of wish that that trailer had cut
itself off about 15 seconds before then
yeah yes I would have loved to have like
what I would have loved to have gotten
out of that was hey we're two people who
clearly are in love with each other and
we got on this thing and oh my god why
did we wake up come see the movie and
find out and and I was thinking about
this with one of the earlier trailers I
watched the alien the original alien
came out when I was 6 and I never saw
the trailer so I i recently watched it
and that's a trailer that would never
get made today because it's not super on
the nose doesn't really tell you
anything about the movie that that would
like let you know what the plot is it's
just like this is kind of the feeling of
this if you're intrigued come see it
which is what I want trailers to do and
if that trailer had ended earlier like I
think but seeing that like there's a
thing I have to tell him like god damn
it knock you like why that like I wish
it had just stopped earlier but that's a
film that I will like I'm intrigued
enough to go see it for sure yeah I mean
I feel like what you just said I'm
always like I wish I
have seen the trailer and just heard
about the premise that I would like rush
out immediately to see it i'm still
going to but I feel the same way I was
like oh this is great and then they
explain it no there's yeah all you have
to do is set up the mystery and then let
me go see the movie no that's all it's
it's it's not rocket science no it's
like it's like the difference between
like a stanley kubrick film and like
event horizon you know you know cuz I
feel like it was like it's like we're
going to that Stanley Kubrick the Ridley
Scott territory and that's like oh okay
we're gonna did you know then it gets
into action film you're like okay yeah
you know I know you die I die yeah i
would also i would also love to see like
one of these movies were like two people
wake up at an unfortunate time and the
last two people in the spaceship and oh
yeah I'm totally gay sorry where
Jennifer Lawrence's like yeah Mike a
really good idea like Mike she's like my
girlfriend's waiting for me I gotta go
dude but we're stuck in space yeah but
you know we let's figure out this how
how do we get back to her let's let's
find some other people to wake up yeah
cuz this party is busted yeah wait wait
I the tyler perry's wig room is on this
[ __ ] head of it well I mean isn't that
just been all of Jennifer Lawrence's
career is trying on different wigs yeah
I'm curious to see this is also the
movie that Jennifer Lawrence I got
something like twenty three million
dollars she got more than chris pratt
was like big news like highest-paid
woman in Hollywood and it's about
[ __ ] time it is honestly yes she's
driven like how many giant movies and
franchises and bike sheet so so uh you
know what she's still selective too
which is great yeah like I me when you
see Jennifer Lawrence in the trailer I'm
like okay well there's something that
made her choose that so it makes me
interested to see you even when it's
except for joy well no yeah
but even that even that like I get I
mean that joy was clearly a misfire but
I but and it didn't deserve a lot of the
Oscar accolades it that it received I
still agreed I mean like it it's the
point is she put some thought into that
decisions based on a true story like
they put the right as team to get people
together to make that film and even
though it didn't really pan out it
wasn't she wasn't like you know Oh
Jennifer Lawrence is doing jack reacher
Madea Halloween like you know it's like
I'm sure it looked really awesome on
paper yeah yeah you know yeah um any any
other like I just love how I like we've
all just sort of settled on this future
look now that's really just like a
throwback to like 60s like 2001 Space
Odyssey and Star Trek yeah like oh I
wish it was like that you know but know
is if it did to me it just for you it
just feels like that like it's like if
you took the Apple Store and made it all
you know everything is perfect white and
it's all this sort of like you know like
you know all of a sudden hallways can't
have right angles in them for some
reason you know because yeah because
curves are futuristic I imagine that
that that a lot of people in this room
and imagine you guys have seen Space
Station 76 and and it is I stumbled upon
it by accident and it is one of my
favorite movies of the last couple of
years and it's a modern sci-fi movie
made as though it were made in the mid
70s and the design aesthetic is of the
mid 70s with those earth tones and and
that we're kind of like ultra-modern
like vacuum-formed plastic everything
and it's so beautiful and it makes me
really hopeful that that's the future we
get not that not the apple store bridge
of the rebooted enterprise future you
want you want levers I totally want
levers I want man I want levers and I
want a spaceship that looks like a
submarine for some reason because that's
kind of because that's kind of like what
we think of I'm just actually I'm okay
with the apple store version because
what I really my fear is is that the
future is going to be some goddamn mad
max Outlander you know no no no that's
the present
held together with duct tape yeah
everything's just like everything's for
sale and it's just like you know it's a
blade runner II we're selling fake snake
organs and something like that which we
have at the merch table after the show
please get a pod fest fake snake organ
yeah I don't know I guess I like more
the dystopian future so I and you know
this even though the trailer like we're
talking about show too much i'm still
excited and interested to see this movie
so i think it's it's set up the mystery
enough i like you said should have left
it alone at a certain point but still
want to see it's the director that did
the imitation game weren't until them so
all right now that's how ya for big
imitation game fans in-house ladies and
gentlemen now there's a this next
trailer this is an interesting trailer
was it's one of these trailers that I I
thought would be kind of polarizing I
thought like some people are going to
have very different reactions to it so
let's play trailer 50 we're here to
connect i love time death now these
three things connect every single human
being on earth we long for love you wish
we had more time we fear death
did you lose a child Howard Howard is a
brilliant creative charismatic guy used
to love life right now he hates it I
tried to talk to him I try to reach him
and he's not there I'm miss him he
writes letters who are they to Howard
doesn't write letters to people he
writes two things time love death kids
write letters Hispanic cause it doesn't
mean they're crazy no this is
therapeutic
who did you write the letter to I rather
let her to death nice to meet you there
charmed I'm sure oh hello people like
that us in the universe all the time
most don't get a personal response that
you are I don't want this I'm time I'm a
gift and you're wasting it you don't
think I'm crazy but I'm having
conversations I am love don't try and
live without me Howard I saw you in her
eyes when she called me daddy and you
betrayed me the reason for everything if
you can accept that then maybe you get
live again
even out the cosmos for pantses
there's so much more at stake here than
you even understand
you've been given a gift his profound
connection to everything
just look for it
I promise you it's there
the collateral beauty yeah yeah ok then
title the title kids Jaden's wind it's
Jaden Smith's tweets the movie
collateral beauty aren't even that like
those words are like that doesn't mean
anything that's like it just never
freshman in college you would have a
boner right now like that that that like
MFA lit program is just like oh yeah so
now I this is exactly what I'm talking
about like some of you thought that was
the most contrived ridiculous thing
you've ever seen and a couple of you and
a couple of you probably went you know I
kind of want to see that yeah I'm gonna
watch the way I think it's awesome that
you raised your hand and you clapped
because like clearly this is a room full
of cynics who are dead inside yeah and
like and you're like no you know what
that made me feel a thing and [ __ ] you
cynics I'm glad that made me feel a
thing another awesome like good for you
good for you for feeling a thing that's
great i'm wearing a batman pajama with a
cape I'm not wearing you might think I'm
doing it to be funny I think I'm going
to fight crime today and make the world
a better place and i'm going to start
writing letters to death and if it's not
Helen Mirren I'm gonna be a little
pissed off if it's the like one from
monty python just don't eat the salmon
mousse yeah I so I I saw that before
movie last week in the theater on the
big screen and I was like and I that is
right in my like sappy wheelhouse I have
I'm so torment I'm such I have such a
split personality there's a part of me
that's just a like nerd cynic that's
like
studios and then like collateral muniz
gonna release me like I just become like
I'm drawing like unicorns in my notebook
it's just like that's gonna be great
we're all gonna learn and we all I
connected and life is like dominoes and
I just I don't know I i I'm gonna wear
this outfit to that movie are you gonna
wait you're gonna cosplay collateral
beauty yes yes I wanna watch this a nice
cosplaying collateral beauty right now
are we all get to realize your lateral
beauty and it did yeah this one punched
me right in the fields as well I I had
hit I sorry I'm sorry point of order sir
punched me right in the fields is this a
scientific term yes point on this human
diagram where the field uh well it's all
just good everywhere man it's knock over
the dominoes and fuel were they land yes
your aura knows it's a Venn diagram
cynicism you know romanticism and then
box office no I love the collateral
beauty circle of it but you know it was
the thing that got me was like okay we
see many dramas about you know loss and
characters dealing with them what I
liked about this i like the
personification of mythical forces of
nature that's the kind of I'm like all
right you know that'd be that'd be kind
of cool like death takes a holiday like
those kind of movies you're black yeah I
always want that one but I just thought
I'd throw that one out there yeah Cecil
you needed there's a distinction I'm
noticing between movies that you think
are good and then just hot actors that
you're like oh my god no I was just like
I was just thinking like the last time
we saw this story about you Joe Black
yeah I was you know four and a half days
long and you know yeah we've met him but
you know like it but yeah uh but you
know there was that like amazing
Twilight Zone episode with uh Paul
Newman I want to say it was like it was
this whole Robert Redford thank you um
that bits this idea like it's this magic
realism you know like take take a force
of nature which I I will totally show up
for
I think you know Chris what you had to
say was was kind of great because I
think we all kind of learned what's on
chris is the secret vision board yes
mystical creatures they talk to him yes
it's no secret yeah ladies and gentlemen
we have two trailers left trailer number
six and this one gram and I were going
to talk about on the podcast but we
enjoyed it so much we said you know what
no we got to save it for the pod fest
show ladies and gentlemen trailer six
oh hell no Frankie mattia in every movie
now a little boy with short curly hair
this is my favorite episode of American
horror story jack reacher was at a
Russian window
wow that's a stellar new resume
my son's been kidnapped if you wait with
me here ma'am will file a report right
now notice me hey wait
yep
let me tell you
as my son
in that car
lots of
right behind you
you took the wrong kid
oh oh my god oh hell no you did not take
my kid I'm gonna just say this real
quick uh jack reacher soccer mom yeah no
I really I feel like this movie they're
like okay I really was hoping that this
movie was called minivan soccer mom of
death it's like every soccer moms
revenge fantasy come to life complete
with many event like the minivan I think
is the star of the film this is holly
berries taken no bacon oh you know what
it was like watch it was like watching
an eye movie trailer template generic
car chase number five that looks like a
joke trailer they run on Saturday Night
Live that does not look like a real
movie but so much respect for turning a
minivan into that thing they did I'd
also like to point out we've now seen
three trailers that have that one
special effect that's in like every like
this is an intense trailer which is like
like that'sthat's like the new star of
every every intense movie trailer it's
the audience for that move in soccer
moms from help like is that is that like
a soccer mom empowerment vanish like a
daily that's that's what it is anyone
who's stuck in traffic you know with
like nine kids in their minivan like
they're all plugged into their things
yeah I think Godzilla would be an
escapist fantasy for someone who's
trapped in traffic
just yeah oh well we got one more this
broke it would just be a garage yeah
we're not done with [ __ ] kidnap oh
alright fair enough uh so the the
minivan mobile um did I see I just want
to make sure I saw the same thing it
went in Reverse didn't hit anything but
caused [ __ ] trucks to just flip on
the thing like that like it looked like
wait is she chasing a hundred kidnappers
in various different cars and trucks and
vans and they like did she have a string
like in that like a cable in the dark
knight like what he used to the cracks
right wire yeah was there like what does
she have does she is she shooting a
Batarang like I can't she is one mom on
a mission that's god damn right she just
like you took the wrong kid all I wanted
to see next as you took the wrong kid
and then like straw in a juice box like
glue like just like a fistful of
goldfish it's on see like she's like me
the crap out of people with like yoga
mats in the back if the last line of
that film is not the kid crawling out of
the car going Oh spoiler alert on that
guy's I a movie precognition spoiler
alert and and so the one I just I'm
dying to know so the one crop or over
and then I'm sure right is he starting
to believe her then the crazy kidnapper
smashes the comp for something I don't
know where what how happy that happened
and then so when she's just taking a
major freeway I'm assuming this was shot
in Georgia for the tax credits so I'm
just when they this is like a 40 car
pileup like
what how is she yeah and having recently
worked in Georgia um the freeways of
Georgia never look like that they are
worse than the freeways in LA true like
I want you to imagine if you could take
the 101 405 interchange and make it 80
miles long and close two lanes for no
reason and then fill it with people who
don't understand what a turn indicator
is in a state where you can talk on your
cell phones while you're driving that's
the highway in Georgia like there is no
way that highway is open like that
shenanigans hashtag hell I and why
doesn't she call like what I kept
presumably like the cell phone like like
it she puts it on the dash and takes a
hard right turn it flies out though when
don't worry was that like she can't ever
call anybody don't even like health or
when I'm rich was being dragged behind
by some car that took her kid that you
know the like we also don't like we live
in a world with like traffic cameras
yeah i clicked more from the team that
brought us transformers and salt mean we
all were gonna solve swing selling some
salt merchandise out here at the table
guys you think i can get it in a back
with the fake snake organs yes I I want
this movie to do well oh and here's why
here's why I gotta have a sequel I gotta
see like this time they got her nice or
whatever like what is it you know like
are they kidnapped like the daycare yeah
whole all the bigger counterpoint the
direct to video on demand sequel is
going to be so much better than the
sequel that goes into the
movies I don't even if we have to look
forward I think this might be like cult
movie fodder like this might be like one
of those movies that 30 years from now
people show up to midnight screenings
for just to see holly berry like right
be like you messed with the wrong you
know like you took the wrong with the
wrong kid yeah I wonder what take that
was like you've got the wrong nearly
that was the first taken it was the only
one they need it we try it again you
took the wrong kid no I will shoot a
little more on it you took the you know
what I'm done use the first when you sit
together I bet yeah I think this is
going to be I think you're right he's
all I think 30 years from now is going
to be like like suburban commando the
Hulk Hogan action comedy I think we're
going to what we're going to line up to
watch this and people are going to all
show up in minivans and yeah a comic con
people are gonna start cosplaying the
minivan yes there's gonna be here that
movie needs to be at a drive-in and
everybody needs to come in and I minivan
haha yeah alright gonna start a kidnap
akan yeah it's just called Amber Alert
Cecil Baldwin ladies a joke yeah that's
all right ready for the final trace go
to our final trailer trailer number
seven please thank you so much
the world is coming undone imperial
flags rain across the galaxy
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
we've a mission for you
a major weapons test is imminent we need
to know how to destroy
are you really doing this I want to help
good
I've been recruiting through the
rebellion for a long time destroyed our
I side the Empire
I fear nothing all is as the force will
see
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
nice there isn't much time
every day they grow stronger
there was a ninety seven point six
percent chance of failure
he means well
this is actual
are you with me
Oh
yes I you know just take my money yes it
doesn't even matter you're getting it
you're getting it no I mean I i know i
got i have a Batman wallet too i guess i
should put mine back in my pocket so
they don't get mixed up yeah yours
probably has more money in it that's
very unlikely was that is that Diego
Luna is like I've like that listen I
know we joke a kid but I will literally
punch any of you to get like one night
with that mouth anyone here I don't care
how big you are you have an odd way of
analyzing films I've been carrying that
torch since a tu mama tambien ok guys
now that looks good as a as a as a like
like a non like I love Star Wars uh but
I'm not like a super fan like this looks
great like you know I'm not into the
mythology but well that's what I think
it looks great about this film you don't
have to be it's just looks like a really
cool it's like you know like a side
story for four star wars I would like to
see a Star Wars movie that doesn't have
a death star in it mmm that would be
maybe my first thing for the note I'd
like to see a kidnap movie without a
minivan and if I hammer wheel yeah
alright it's not gonna happen
III love Star Wars I saw the original
star wars in the theater when I was a
little boy I saw Empire and Jedi in
theater then the whole prequel thing
happened I would interrupt you right
there and I want to say that for with us
like with our age seeing those movies
and that there's nothing like yeah it's
really as a kid and those movies in the
movie theater was an amazing experience
uh and and uh it was like super
formative in my like identity and it
kind of like I already enjoyed science
fiction but I wasn't crazy in love with
it because they didn't have those images
and that emotional impact of those
things and I I hated all the prequels
and I just don't particularly care for
the extended universe and actually
avoided seeing trailers for the force
awakens had no intention of seeing the
force awakens and I had been avoiding
this trailer I didn't seen until just
now I'd like I didn't want to see it
you're welcome I yeah well yeah so
that's like all preamble to like that
looks great yeah like that looks like a
movie that I really want to see and and
when my wife and I saw saw force awakens
like probably like four or six weeks
after it opened and we just like it
wasn't a priority cuz she's like I don't
know and I had a bunch of friends I went
to the premiere and I remember so
Hardwicke came out of the of the the
premiere and i just texted him and I was
like so on a scale of like 12
midi-chlorians how much am I going to
hate this movie and he said I I really
think you're gonna love it it's you know
it has its flaws but that's it but
they're okay and so we would see it and
I walked in and she was like what you
think and I was like I I loved it i I'm
so exciting I loved Star Wars again and
that that that trailer does the same
thing for me yes so I'm I'm I'm very
very excited for it and now what are the
things that made force awakens so much
fun for me even with its flaws is that I
had no expectations and now but but I
that looks really cool and I'm like
god damn it I have expectations again
you know like it's gonna let me down it
can't not let me down now I will say
this that looks great uh what one little
thing that I'm curious about that we
didn't see in that trailer one of the
reasons I love Star Wars is is the kind
of you know universe building and like
you know the every planet is a very
specific thing and the you know every
like leaf on every plant and every
creature this looks a little like plain
plain ish like it's a little italy you
know like we're maybe they're saving
some of the good stuff but it's you know
it's like okay we got the Death Star we
got some space stations you know it's
good to see a nap at every once a while
is in the jungle that's awesome yeah
yeah but open Amelia I you know like
that that classic like sci-fi like we
are gonna build the hell out of this
world maybe we'll get the season the
both in a home world since you know so
many of them died to bring the plans
well I think that's I think that's oh
it's the second death star [ __ ] and turn
in mannered card sorry you guys it's
just that Jack Reacher really rattled me
I i I'm every time I see this movie this
trailer I think it's gonna be I think
it's gonna be amazing and here's why cuz
and I said this before in the show but
watching is gonna even hearing what you
guys have to say you know force awakens
was was great and yes it wasn't perfect
it had its flaws and force awakens had
to kind of do certain things it had to
have that cast looks [ __ ] reparations
for thank you no no it was reparations
it literally had to get us back to zero
yeah let's be honest guys the prequels
were hate crimes so uh that's what set
to you off yeah it's that that's been
dancing we lost the audience that's a
weird place for a loser
so many places we could have lost them
already yeah that was the 160 hell knows
we're fine hello Bram so so for light
guys making fun of medea totally fine
we're cool with that um no I'm fine i
love my dear labor of love we are you me
just go to the tape on Cecil talking
about Medea haha oh I have to tell you
what i'd like to see his madea's wig I
do know that's that's a sincere and
honest way if y no irony there if it's
like uh any of the guys he's listen
tonight we're like in those Medea wigs I
think he would explode that's it I think
Cecil would just oh my god yes
absolutely what let me say this what was
first Whittaker wearing was that he was
wearing a battlefield earth out said
yeah yeah no here's what here's what I
wanted to say that like I think this
movie is going to be awesome because
it's going to take all of the great
things about Star Wars and all of the
great things about this new expanded
universe and it's going to be it's going
to have no restrictions it's not going
to have the the nerd scrutiny on it of
force awakens and it doesn't have the
nostalgia factor or doesn't have to do
that we can just tell an amazing story
in this universe in such a cool way and
it's it's like it's they just took like
a line from you know a new hope I though
many Bothans died for this we're gonna
see a whole movie when you first heard
that as a kid you're like who the [ __ ]
are the buttons have a look at this
happen well oh my god how do they die
like this is crazy we're gonna see 90
minutes to 2 hours at the whole boffin
backstory I'm so excited for this I'm
gonna by Bothan pajamas you know what I
really loved about this too and I know
we're looking this through fan excited
glasses but I feel like as you watch
this trailer like every beat him like
yes yes yes yes cool stuff a strong
female lead back story that I was really
curious about before robust
cool caricature yes a large droid that
may actually kill people like things
like there's like a yes yeah every
single one so I'm excited to see it
again we have fan goggles but I don't
care again also also as a trailer that
shows me enough to get me excited and
intrigued me yes overwhelming me with
big we're telling me everything yeah
yeah whoo looks like no one said why did
we wake up early right yeah and also the
other thing too of like in terms of the
casting of it I'm like donnie yen as a
blind Jedi yes yes stand up and clap
bring yeah it's like you're taking the
tooth of my most favorite worlds and
you're putting them together in one
thing if one of them was like oh here's
someone's Owain like it like it was
yours like they just somehow we fit into
Gotham I don't care how like this I
would like this is [ __ ] awesome and
add cage fighting and if you just do
that oh and vegan smoothies and
surfboards if you just added those
things um no I'm you have just described
the greatest fan fiction of all time
somebody right inside waiting five
standing by he said oh yeah all you have
to do is add a sexy vampire and you'll
be a millionaire no in a madea wig so
soon so we'll watch it well ladies and
gentlemen we do have to wrap up but
before we go we want to talk a little
bit more to our guests will what do you
have coming up and where can people find
you on the Internet uh you can find me
my blog which is it wil wheaton dotnet
you can find me on the twitter where I
recommend you do not follow me because
I'm the worst but that is at will W I'm
it's wil wheaton on facebook and
instagram and I'm wil wheaton that
tumblr com and I know I'm forgetting one
I you I don't snapchat that much but I'm
it's wil wheaton on the snapchats and at
some point between now on the heat death
of the universe legendary is going to
release the third season of four seats
for season three with the next season of
my show tabletop
I don't know when they keep delaying it
and and it's totally out of my hands but
hopefully sometime soon maybe even
before the end of the year and I'm
writing a book right now and it is
presently untitled but I will hopefully
also be up before the end of the year is
it kidnap the minivan story or I'm
retooling the third act right now based
on new information soccer mom of death
I'm and see so will you wait wait
because this is a podcast audience
either this podcast with my friend Mikey
Newman that I'm really proud of that I
really like that I want you all to
listen to it's called TV crimes and well
Mikey and I watch TV shows from the 70s
to the 90s and we do a recap of what the
show is kind of about and then we put it
on trial for its crimes it's really fun
and it's really silly and Mikey does an
amazing podcast and YouTube show called
movies with Mikey where he does these
amazing incredible like like breakdowns
of what make movies work so he brings
that sensibility and I bring my like
angry dead inside cynicism hahaha the
thing we kind of meet in the middle and
you can find it at TV crimes net and and
then we're on all the different podcast
networks and stuff but I just really
really like it and I'm really proud of
it and and we're very small I think we
have like maybe six thousand listeners
or something like that but I'm super
proud of it and I hope that maybe we'll
get a little bit of new audience from
people who are hearing about it for the
first time today all right
that may have been the most enthusiastic
best plug ever from again and see so
where can people find you and you got
some more night Vale stuff coming up
yeah yeah you can find me on Twitter and
Instagram at Cecil Baldwin III because
I'm the third in my family and Facebook
and yeah if you're if you're watching
this live streaming or if you're
watching this internationally uh the
month of October night Vale is going on
tour to 15 different cities around
Europe pray for me uh although
admittedly it's going to be really
interesting watching the election happen
from not America so I'll pack a lot of
bags yeah currently looking for my new
British husband yeah I know the you know
what they tell every American tourists
in Europe say you're Canadian yes yes uh
and then if you happen to be in London I
believe I can say this uh too much light
makes the baby go blind I'm going to be
doing a three-week run of that play in
London first three weeks of November
all right uh yeah so we've got ear buds
is thank you guys who came last night I
feel great so we've got a couple more
festivals we're doing and then ear buds
will be for sale mid November at comedy
film Ernst calm all you Kickstarter
backers will get it first yeah except
that creepy guy I don't want to know
what you're going to do with that dude
but this is the sellings Russ my drawing
of things Ted Levine Ted Lilly movie
nobody ever loves really I'd listen to
me didn't they we're gonna get a ted
levine impression on the show today guys
but excuse me sir a very bad ted levine
impression oh so yeah earbuds and then
of course anybody listening to this you
know all of these videos are going to be
available on the lime street for the
next 30 days you can use coupon code to
save time five dollars CFN we also just
added coupon code wheaton and that money
goes to will so we'll plug that on your
that's actually a coupon code just just
to be clear if using coupons it's the
other thing but wheaton is the coupon
code so save five dollars with your
coupon i but i am i sir am a
traditionalist yeah when you're on your
handheld rob't yes I think this Italian
it looks like wil wheaton clipping
coupons yes there's your book yes a pick
up that live in coop in the from wil
Wheaton's bookstore um yep and uh you
know yeah check out his video podcast
table tip people do and it'll come out
on a Tuesday yeah so guys also so we're
having a little break in the action so
starting right downstairs right now at
five-thirty is the happy hour so it's
theirs if you just go down the stairs
there's a bar lounge area just off the
lobby
check that out after you buy some merch
yeah and it's a it's a cash bar then
there's appetizers and stuff like that
so go down and check that out and of
course tell your friends follow us at
Comic this is our fifth year doing this
at the festival it's you guys are so
couldn't do it without you guys thank
you so much it's been a lot of work this
year there's been some additional
challenges and so to have you guys all
come up to us like last night today like
saying how great you live this festival
how much it means to you and people
thought your buds is just like brings me
to tears it's so appreciative you guys
are my collateral they're collateral
beauty yeah collateral beauty i forgot
the second word of that joke you you are
my collateral damage you guys are all
collateral damage any you know what
you've done so thank you once again to
wil wheaton cecil Baldwin the tech staff
and everyone the volunteers give them a
round of applause uh my name is Graham
Elwood and I'm Chris Mancini and as
always remember hotshot first thank you
guys